早速 今日のテーマに沿って話したいと思います
で 仏教は世の中ね 宗教だと思ってますけど
他の宗教とは お釈迦様の教えはね
違うところはこれは学ぶ世界なんですね
信仰する世界ではないんです
と言ってもね 仏教は崩れていったところで
ちゃんとした宗教に退化しましたけどね
まあチベット仏教とかね
日本とかね 中国とかいろいろ大乗仏教の世界も
それから今現在テーラワーダ仏教という世界もね
結局はまあ宗教に退化したんですね
なぜ退化という言葉を使いますかというと
お釈迦様が現れた時代も
宗教はむちゃくちゃたくさんあった時代なんですね
経典にも 62ぐらい宗教ありましたと言ってますからね
宗教のもう森の中でお釈迦様がもう森を開いて空き地を作ったんですね
オープンスペースを だからそれまた宗教になってしまったといえば
これ退化ですね ですから
こちらの組織もテーラワーダ仏教なんだらかんだら言うんですけど
実際 タイ スリランカのテーラワーダ仏教っていうのは
結局は宗教なんですよ
で 当然修業したり 瞑想したり
真面目に頑張ったりする方々は当然たくさんいますけど
一般人の間ではまあ一つの宗教になっているんです
私はあんまりこのテーラワーダ仏教
なんだらかんだらというのは
何かレッテル貼ってないと
みんなもうもう迷惑みたいなことを言うんだからね
私は何も名前を付けたくはなかったんですね
一応お釈迦様の教えということでね
法律上でも宗教にせなくちゃいけないしね
そういうことで お釈迦様の教えっていうのは
勉強して勉強して実践して人格向上する世界なんですね
だから信仰する世界ではないんです
だからお釈迦様はいつでもこのインテリの人々が出てこいと
すぐ理解できますよと
いつでもこのインテリの人々に呼びかけているんですよ
だから頭が悪い人はちょっとよく知らないんですけど
だから 科学的に物事を考える
客観的に物事を考える
自分で判断するっていうしっかりした人々に対する教えなんですね
現代的に言えば アメリカとかね
無神論という人々がいるんですね
あのエティスという人々がね
この無神論の方々は決まって超エリートなんですよ
一番キリスト教が盛んになっているのはアメリカなんですね
ヨーロッパもそんなに
イタリアさえもね ほとんど教派がないんですね
あまりにも原始的ということでね
アメリカですね もうかなり派手に狂暴で
ということは バカが多いということなんですよ
で それでそれはアメリカもアメリカとまたイギリスでは
この無神論の方々ね 日本でもよく知ってますね
生物学者の何々さんでしたっけ
今も彼が書いた新しい本を今最近書いた本も読んでますけどね
で その無神論者は超エリートで
宗教は絶対信じませんと
だからそういうタイプの人々に結構合う教えなんですね
だからといって 現代の無神論者たちは
ただゴタゴタゴタゴタ喋るだけで
人間というのは人格的に向上するべきだというところまで進んでいないんです
このままでいいわけじゃないっていうのは
お釈迦様の違うところなんですよ
これは当たり前の事実なんですよ
このままで我々はいいわけじゃないんです
そこで道が 2つありますね
皆さんもそう思っているし
世界もそう思ってますね
このままで良くないと
そこでなんとか成長しなくちゃいけないと
いて 世の中では建物作るは
車作るはとかね まあ地球の化石燃料を全部掘り出して使い切っちゃうわとかね
自然破壊するわとか 戦争するわとか
ハチャメチャなことをやってますよ
あれも結局このままではちょっと問題ということのこと
例えば服にしたっても
まあひどい世界でしょう
デザイナーたちがいるわ
バランブラン ブランドの品物があるわ
もうどうでもいい服なんだけど
えらい超高い値段で買わなくてはいけないんですね
なんであんな値段かかるんですかね
あんなくだらない服に
だから材料費とそれぞれの利益だけ足せればいいでしょうに
このブランドつけちゃうと
それだけでも 10 20万
15 万つけなくちゃいかんでしょ
だから泥棒なんですよ
まあとにかくこのままでダメだということで人々は頑張っているんですね
では その道でいいんですかね
問題は 私たちは幸せになってますかね
世の中は変わってますよ
私たち生まれてから生まれた世界じゃないんだから
今住んでいる世界は もう相当違う世界になっているんですね
だからって何かいいことあるんですかね
うん で 変わるだけでね
で そういうことで この無神論者の方々もね
これでいいのかっていうことをね
考えてほしいんですよ
神はもうウイルスだというのは構わないんだけど
同じ先生がね ゴッドウイルスという本も書いてありますからね
これね きちんと生物学的に説明してありますけど
だからといって 人間っていうのはそのままではいいわけじゃないんですね
神を信仰したっても 何か何か開祖様を信仰したってもね
我々の人生は良くなるわけじゃないんですね
良くなるために無茶苦茶に仕事をしたってもね
金儲けたっても 隣の国に行って戦争したってもね
それでいいわけじゃないんでしょうに
はい ということで テーマに入りましょう
はい 仏教は学ぶ世界で
学ぶは 2種類ありますね
1つは知識 技術 能力などの学び
これは皆様よく知っていて
大体どんな人間もある程度でやってます
国によってこれは変わったりもしますしね
結構前はね 日本もね 学識的には結構強かったし
今はかなり落ちてますけどね
で この落ちるのをなんか日本人がすごい喜んでいるみたいですね
で 頑張らないんですね
で いろんな国々でね まあそれぞれ国の経済状況に合わせて
まあ教育っていうものをやっているんですね
で 学校なくても何か学ばなくては生きていられないでしょ
アフリカの部族のね ブッシュマンにしたっても
生まれてばっかりでは生活はできませんよ
アメリカの森の中なんか住んでいる人々は
まあ三点ぐらいの視力を持って
暗闇でもものすごく見えて
だから微妙な声も聞こえて
それで判断して 生きてますね
だから彼らにとっては生まれつき視力が良くて
聴覚が良くて だからそんな話じゃないんですよ
聴覚もそれなりに育てなくちゃあかんでしょ
で 普通はかなり音を我々は聞かないで無視するんです
脳に入らないんです だから皆様と違って
この部族社会で森で生活する人々は微妙な音も聞いているんです
そこで派手に風が吹いて
木がゆらゆらしている時はものすごい音でしょうに
その中から微妙な音を取り出して聞き分けるんです
だからそれを学んでいるんですよ
だから学びっていうのは必ずしも学校でやることっていうわけじゃないんです
ただ 生きるために欠かせない作業なんですよ
2番目 人格の向上 残念ながら
これとても大事だと誰も言ってないんです
仏教はこの 2番目の学問なんです
1 はもうみんなやってるんだから勝手にやってくださいと
2番目 戦争的に仏教はやってるんです
だから 2種類の学問があるんです
誰もやってないのは 2番目なんです
でも気づいてはいますよ
みんな 学校崩壊とかね
国はもういろいろ問題が起きたりとかね
これではダメですとかね
まあ例えば中国やら自分の国やらインドやら
政治家が政治家は賄賂を取ることを政治家の仕事であると思っているしね
これでは国は良くなるわけないでしょ
その政治家だけですからね
日本も同じですけど もう民主主義と言い張りながら選挙に出るのは政治家の親戚だけなんですね
息子たちだけなんですね
これは英語ではネポティズムと言いますけどね
とても悪い言葉なんですけど
自分と自分の親戚だけ
国の財産を食っちゃうと
だからそれはインドも同じで
自分の国も明確にやっているし
はい そういうことは良くない
良くないとしってますね
学校で子供たちが乱暴したり
窓ガラスを割ったり 教師を殴ったりしちゃうと
これ困りますと だから性格は悪ければ大変やということは
まあ結構ひどい目に遭ってるんだから
まあなんとなくうすらと気づいているんだけど
それだけ やっぱりそれより金儲けの方がいいやと
で終わってるんです だから日本の学校でもなんか道徳という授業があるみたいですけど
あれは一番人気のない授業なんですね
道徳授業をする先生たちももう大変ですね
教えられないんですね
まあ一つ 自分でも知らないってこともありますけど
自分でも知らなくたっても
子供たちをまとめて興味を引き出すことは難しいんですね
まあなくてもいいんじゃないという感じなんですよ
しかし 考えてください
道徳なくなるともう人類の終わりなんですよ
そこで仏教も知識的に終末論を語っているんで
あれは別にその通りになるかならないかわかりませんだけど
なんか宗教の人々はみんな偉そうに終末論を語るんだからね
明日何があるかも言える能力ないくせに
キリスト教であろうが
イスラム教であろうが
ヒンドゥー教であろうが
もう明日どうなるかわからないんですよ
あの連中は なのに終末それを偉そうに語るんです
信じるバカがいるんだからどうしようもないんですよ
でまあというか 脅し論ですね
あれは そんな変なことあるんだから
仏教もそれに知識バージョンを作っているんです
人間はどんどん道徳を後回しにして
金儲けだけ優先にするんだと
金儲けを優先すると 当然怒りもついてくるんです
欲と怒りっていうのは
コインの表と裏なんです
欲だけ怒り何ともないとありえないんです
欲がある時 怒りがないんです
裏と表ですからね 欲はちょっと叶わないなとわかったら
ガクッとコインが逆になるって激怒になってしまうんです
そこで人間が 欲と怒りを中心に儲かるだけで十分だと思って
ゴラゴラと五欲にふけるんだと
食うこと 遊ぶこと 性行為すること
あれこれやりたい放題やり出しましょうと
そうすると道徳を犯すんですね
不丈夫な行為もするし
邪な行為もするし 暴行も起こすし
それで欲ですからね 強盗もするし
強盗すると政府では取り調べなくなっちゃうと
お互い様 自分たちでアメリカがやっているような
自分の家に入った人を殺すのは権利あるんですね
だからそうやって自分の手で人を殺したりして
どんどん道徳的に落ちて落ちていくんだと
そうなってくると 人間の寿命が短くなるんだと
それなんか神秘的に感じますね
いいえ それは科学的なんです
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ 恨みで脳が働くと
寿命が短くなるんです
全細胞が燃えているんです
火傷しているんです だから遺伝子は変化するんです
今の我々の遺伝子はスーッと変化しているんです
それが怒り 嫉妬 憎しみで
欲で 強情で 傲慢で 体中そのホルモンを出して出しっぱなしでいると
よく正しく変化しないでしょ
それでどんどん寿命が縮めちゃうし
醜くなっていくんです
そうなってくると みんな均等に醜くなるわけじゃないんだから
均等に寿命が減ることもないんだから
お互いまた差別し合ったり
人をバカにしたりするんだと
それでさらに怒り 嫉妬
憎しみが増えるんだと
で さらに寿命が短くなるんです
人々の心が悪くなってくると
資源が消えてしまいますよと
畑 田んぼを作ってもなかなか実らないんだと
それは当たり前なんです
実っても栄養がないんだと
それ食べるとさらに体が今も起きてるんだからね
欲で欲で農業やってるんだから
もう結局毒食べてるんですね
だから栄養がなくなるんだと
そうするとさらに病気になったり
寿命が縮んだりする 寿命が縮めば縮むほど
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ 生存欲
どんどん強烈になってくる
お釈迦様がおっしゃっている順番が科学的には正しいんです
神話的なエピソードはどうかわからないんです
そこで最終的に まあ人間の寿命は七年に縮みますよと
それで生まれて大人になって
子供を作って老いて七年で死ぬんだと
で ずいぶん最近 ある子供向けの小説を読んだんですね
あの科学サイエンスフィクションなんですけど
そちらでもこの七年 寿命の人間の世界を語ってるんです
ストーリーがね 地球ではなくて
こちら宇宙船からどうか行ったところで
なんか事故っちゃって
どうかの星に落ちちゃって
まあそこはあまりも強烈に太陽があって
もうもう昼はもう燃えすぎちゃって
夜は寒すぎちゃって だから人間がもう山の中に隠れて生活して
まあ二 三時間しか外に出られないんだと
まあそういうストーリーで
七年で死ぬというね その時もこの一日二
三時間しか活動できない
その間で食べるか殺し合いやるかなんですね
そのストーリーの中で
だからこのアメリカの小説家がね
妄想して書いたものでも
なんかよく経典にあるお話によく合ってます
合うんですね で それでこの七年の寿命の人間が大人になって子供を作って年取って死にますけど
いつでも互いに殺し合いやってるんだと
あの小説であったのは
誰かを殺したらその人の寿命は自分がいただくんだという迷信があるんだと
それはお釈迦様は入れてないんですけど
現代小説家が入れただけで
もしかするとそれも入れた方が良かったなと思います
だって だってなんでもう短い時間だからね
平和でいればいいでしょ
殺し合いやるんだと そこで文化も人類も全部ほとんど破滅するんだと
どんな人間の手にも武器があるんだと
だから人間を見ると 同じ人間
同類の人間だと思わないんだと
餌 孫という あいつは獣やと
という気持ちになっちゃって
殺し合いやって それで一部の人々はなんとことですかと
これはと言ってまた山に隠れるんだと
洞窟に 家族だけで逃げて
一部の人々は隠れて 他の人間と関係なくじっと隠れ生活していて
家族ですから殺し合いやる必要もないし
七年で死ぬでしょうし
それでまあ欲はなくなっちゃうでしょ
微妙に減っていくでしょうに
で 森の中 山の中だから自然のもの
落ちたものを取ったり食べてるんだから
またじわじわじわじわと寿命が延びるようになるんだと
それで最初に我々の文化が
文明が滅するになったのは
この殺しやっていたんだからと
殺しはやめましょうと
そこからまた道徳がスタートするんです
それでまた人間の文明がどんどん開花していくんだというエピソード
お釈迦様が書いている
説かれているんですね
だからそこは必ずその通りになると思わなくてもいいんです
お釈迦様がすごい智慧の完成した方だから
あのエピソードで我々に何かを教えてるんですよ
いかに道徳的な生き方が我々にとって欠かせない大事なことであると
金ではないんだよと 我々の寿命
幸福 幸せ の決定するものは道徳的な生き方なんです
他に他何でもないんです
金でも科学でも何でもとんでもないんです
金がなくても 科学がなくても
人間にはバンバンさえ幸せでいられます
長生きすることもできます
何もなくても 一つだけ道徳が必要です
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみはダメです
道徳といったら 宗教で言っている
この何か決まりを守るという迷信的な道徳ではないんです
心理学的で 心にある汚れが発動しないように
抑えておかなくちゃいかんです
心の汚れをなくすか 麻痺しておくか
目覚めないようにしておくか
これなんですね 仏教道徳というのはそういうことで
この 2番目の学問は 仏教はあえて解くものですね
一は世間的な学問です
この世で幸福に生きることを敵
ライバル 障害になるものを抑えて勝利を得ることを目指していますね
1 ではそれですね だから欲と怒りなんですね
この目的に合わせて性格が変わったり変えたりもしますが
優先的な価値はありません
と言ったのは この言葉はちょっと難しいかもしれませんだけど
我々も勉強したりすると
技術を学んだりすると
ある程度で性格変わるんですよ
でも やむをえず変わっただけで
計画的に変えたわけじゃないんです
それも欲 目的で 怒り 目的で変わるんです
たくさん儲かるために睡眠時間を減らすとかね
そんな感じなんです それから軍隊に入ったら
無理やりに洗脳して性格変えるんですね
もうアメリカ軍人以外はだいたい軍人というのは結構よく性格的にできているんです
自分の国でもね 国民は最低なんですけど
軍人はしっかりしたいい若者たちなんですよ
しっかり性格を育てているんです
だから結構人気あるんです
で 軍隊に入ったらね あえて無理やりに性格を変えますよ
しかし 目的は軍人 決まっているでしょうに
だから私たちの世界でも性格は変わる
皆様にしたっても 皆様の 100年の前にいた日本の方々の性格と皆様の性格は随分変わってますね
これ変わっただけで 計画的に良い方向に意図的に変えたわけじゃないんですね
そこで2番目 仏教の人格向上を目指す
目指して学ぶ これは仏教が推進する学びですね
人格完成 一切の苦しみを乗り越えることを目指して学ぶんです
仏教は 仏教という教えは人格完成のためにやるんですよ
だから仏教はいる必要もいらない人もっていうのはちょっとおかしいんです
すべての人類には仏教は欠かせないものなんです
宗教だったら好き勝手で
好みで選んでもいいんだけど
これは宗教ではないんですよ
正しく生きる方法ですから
正しく生きる方法っていうのはみんなに必要でしょうね
それから一切の苦しみを乗り越えることを目指すんですね
もうはっきりしていますよ
科学発展で人間の苦しみは消えません
経済発展で人間の苦しみが消えません
文学があっても人間の苦しみが消えません
芸術あるからといって我々の苦しみが消えません
別な方法はあるんです
それを仏教は教えているんです
タイプ 1 の知識能力などを身につける学びについて
仏教は優先的な価値は与えていません
だから仏教はこのタイプ 1 の場合は
これは優先的にということはないんです
しかし 皆様はやっぱり学校に行って学ぶことはもう優先だよと思って
もう子供たちにもうそうやって教育を強引に押し付けるんですね
でもそれは優先大事じゃないんです
そこを勘違いしている
だからそれから問題が来るんです
私は一応実験したことがあるんです
かなり前 自分の国でまるっきり勉強したくない
もう勉強は絶対やらないという子供が何人かいて
もう一度乱暴で学校に無理に行かせちゃっても
先生と喧嘩して出てくるんです
どうしようもないんです
最悪一人がどちらかというと自分の名前さえもろくに書けないんです
もう乱暴というと切りがないんです
私はその子供たちと仲良くしてね
まあ結構付き合ってみたんです
で それで何を教えたかというと
こいつは勉強嫌いだからね
全然教えてません ただ
どうやって優しい人間になるのか
それはどんな意味があるのか
なんで乱暴なことをしてはいけないのかと
なんでみんなに嫌われる行動をやってはいけないのかと
そういうことをすごく対話的に教えていって教えたんですね
で 仲良くしたんだから
なんでお前あの人を殴ったんですか？とこいつに聞くんですね
だからすごい信頼されているんだから
こういうわけで こういうわけで
こういうわけで こうなったんだよ
そうですかね でもあんたにはね
まあこれまずいでしょう
こうした方がよかったな
あんた頭が悪いんだからとかね
言うと こいつは なるほど
そういう方法もあるんだと
それで学ぶんですね それでその子たちがまあ十五六になってくると
もうみんな村の人気者に変わってしまったんです
誰でも信頼する だから勉強してないんだからって問題ないんです
みんな信頼する それでみんな結構豊かで
今も生きています 今もうおじいさん
じじいになってますけど
あのグループはみんな経済的に何の問題もなく
家族の中で全然何の問題もなく
随分性格のいい子供たちもいて
なんかリーダーみたいな感じで生きているんです
学問は 0 どんな偉い人と何のことなくしゃべる
誰でも信頼する だからそこで私はこの人体実験して何をやったかというと
どちらが優先かと どちらが欠かせないのか
生きるために ちゃんと儲かってますよ
もう結構豊かで ある若者に私は文句を言ったことがあります
その時 私は大学で教師をやっていたんです
こいつは学校を卒業してないんです
中学校は なんとか名前書けるだけで
お前はね お前は学校に行かないくせに
私より 3倍収入あるでしょうにと
私は苦労して勉強して
もう徹夜して もう勉強して研究してね
もう教師になって スリランカ一番トップグレードの仕事してますけど
この野郎 なんだこれ お前とは
とか まあまあ仲良くいろいろ悪口言ったんですけど
でもその時もまあ怒りで言ったわけじゃなくて
本人もニコッと笑って話は終わりましたけど
私が自分の実験なんですね
だから 俗世間的な学問より道徳的な学問が勝っちゃったんです
これは世界どこでも同じ法則ですよ
2つの学問も必要不可欠ですが
タイプ 1 は条件付きで付きで役に立ちます
ちょっと引っ掛けありますよ
この学問では技術では条件付きなんですよ
例えば皆様方はね 誰かさんがギリシャ語を学んだっても金にならないね
条件があるんですよ まあ誰かがギリシャ語をあんたわかってるんだから
これ翻訳頼みますよと言われたら金になります
でなかったら馬鹿にされます
あいつでも役に立たんこと勉強して
まあアホじゃないかと言われるんです
考古学を学んだんだからといって
条件付きですよ 収入が得るか得ないかという
技術の場合も同じこっちゃでしょ
だから学問 技術 技術はいつだって役に立ちますよじゃないんです
時と場合によります それから病気になったら
年取ったらどうなるんですかね
役に立たない それから学ぶものはどうしても頭から落ちるんですよ
だからずっと知識はピンピンでいられませんよ
落ちるんです 衰えるんです
そこは問題です タイプ 2 は無条件的に役に立ちます
タイプ 2 はそうじゃないんです
24時間無条件で役に立ちます
またありますけどね 次に別なテーマで考えましょう
学ぶ必要ありますか？というね
輪廻転生するならば すべての生命が学ばなくてはならないという運命なようなものです
どうしようもないんです
学ばなくてはいけないという運命を背負っているんです
我々人間だけじゃないんです
輪廻転生するすべての生命が
生まれただけで生きていられません
学ぶこと 本当につまらない
ですよ ミミズとして生まれたら
生まれただけでは生活できませんよ
ミミズはミミズとして生きて死ぬまでの間
生きるために必要なものを学んでいるんです
あの微生物も同じなんですよ
必要なものを学んでいるんです
今ありますね 病院なんかでは
なんとかあのなんとか細菌がありますね
なんていったっけ あれは
あの あの殺菌できない
あのなんとかブドウ球菌
なんとかっていうね 結構頑丈になってますね
だって病院で毎日毎日強烈な殺菌剤でもうきれいにきれいにすると
細菌たちは これはどうたまったもんじゃないやと
言って学んで体変えたんですよ
だからウイルスにしたっても
いろんな方法で感染するルート
自分たちがそれぞれ持ってるでしょ
だから体に 例えば神経に感染するか
血液に入るか 細胞に入るかとか
それ決まってる それちゃんとそちらに行くんだから
インフルエンザウイルスだったらどこで感染するべきか知ってますよ
医学は別挙していないんだけど
それ知らなかったらウイルスはもう存続できないでしょ
だから生き延びることっていうのは
学びによって成り立つんです
どんな生命も死ぬのは嫌なんです
だったら生き延びなくちゃあかん
だったら学ばなくてはあかんという順番です
だから人間だけ なんでこの勉強はやりたくない
あれやこれやと言ってる場合じゃないと思いますよ
これはもう運命ですね
だから私の言葉の鵜呑みにしたってもいいんだけど
私は勉強嫌やと言ったら
お前人間に生まれたことが間違いやと
それだけ そう言わずにお願いしますから勉強してちょうだいとか
私はそう言いません お前のせいだと
なんで人間に生まれた
犬になった方が良かったのにと
人間になれと頼んだわけじゃないし
勝手に人間に生まれたように勉強しろよと
で 話は終わり 嫌だったら
ではでは犬扱いしますよと
まあまあ かわいいんだからね
犬扱いしますよと その優しくする必要ないんですよ
それが事実ですから 私が一回言ったらよく聞きます
どれぐらいのことを知ることができるか
学べるかということで
生命の価値が決められます
生命にはそんな価値がないんだけど
すべての生命は平等ですけど
まあ現実的にはあります
例えば人間に学べる量と犬に学べる量っていうのは違うでしょ
そこで一時的な価値が成り立つんです
で 犬が犬に学べる量と猫が学ぶ量
また違うんですね これで価値が違うんです
そこで仏教はね  この地球上だけじゃなくて
地獄があるし 餓鬼道があるし
天界があるし 梵天があるしね
まあ輪廻五道ですからね
いろんな次元の生命がいるんですね
この生命の次元がなんで出来上がっているのかというと
この知る量なんですね
知る量と生き延びるためにどれぐらい苦労しなくちゃいけないかという
生き延びることは苦労で成り立つんです
それで地獄っていうのは極端に苦を味わえないと生きていられないし
餓鬼道は相当苦しい生き方をしているし
動物畜生という動物世界はそれ結構苦しんで生活しているし
次の人間は まあ我々も結構苦しんで生きているんですね
それで上天界梵天になってくると
苦がもうかなり減っていくんです
梵天になってくると もう微妙な苦しかないんです
だからといって 仏教は生まれて死んでから天国に行きましょうという話はしません
仏教という宗教はやってますけど
お釈迦様の教えではそういうふうには言いません
死後 新たに生まれるたびに命はリセットされますので
新たに学ぶ羽目になります
悔しいでしょうね 輪廻転生するんだから死んじゃいますよ
死んじゃったら 持ってる生命エネルギーに合わせてどこかに生まれ変わるんです
そうすると今まで学んだものは全部リセット
またゼロからやらなくちゃいけない
例えば 数学者の先生が死んじゃって
犬のお母ちゃん 赤ちゃん
お母さんのお腹に生まれたら
数学役に立つと思う？役に立ちません
お手とかね バーンといったらゴロンと転がる
それぐらいで十分です
それ初めから学ばなくちゃあかんです
今まで学んだものは全部リセット
これが輪廻なんです だって皆様も生まれてから全部一から
初めから学んだでしょ
今 今の年になってくると
学んだものはピークが過ぎちゃってね
今はもうどんどん落ちてる時期でしょ
死ぬ間際になると もうほとんどもう学者でも誰でも同じですね
結局は ただボロボロで死ぬでしょう
学問役に立たないんです
それで死んじゃったらすべてゼロ
はい これ 皆様方は優先第一にして学ぶのはその学問なんです
生き延びるための学問
学んでもこの寿命に限るんです
それは 死でリセットします
これ言うためにお釈迦様がちょっと自慢した話があります
お釈迦様はこう言うんです
私はいくら年取っても
私の知恵は衰えませんよと
たとえ話を言うんです
もし私は寝たきりになって
体洗うことやら立てることやらね
食べることやら 大便小便やら
全部他の人をやる羽目になっても
知恵はピカピカですよと
それで4人の人が来て
次から次へと質問しても
私は答えますよと あれはお釈迦様は俗世間的な学問じゃないんだ 2
番目の人格向上の学問やったんです
それはリセットされません
衰えません それ言いたかったんです
で 私はリセットとかね
この現代用語を使うんだけど
そういう単語はブッダの時代ではなかったんです
だから私はブッダをもうこの 20 何世紀でしたっけ？わかりませんだけど
21 世紀に紹介したいんで
だから 21 世紀 いう言葉を使っているだけ
しかし 生命は生まれてから死ぬまで
命を繋ぐために必要なことしか学ばないんですね
かわいそうで みんな学ぶんだけど
生まれてから死ぬまで役に立つものしか学ばないんです
で 死んじゃったらもうそれは役に立たない
リセットされます また始めなくちゃあかん
ただ 皆様がここで死んじゃって
ここではないんです このセロホウではなくてね
この世の中で死んじゃって
どこか人間で生まれたとしましょう
じゃあ今学んだものは持っていく？持っていかない
また丸描いたり もう落書き描いたり
そこから始めなくちゃあかんです
ですから 死後あの世に持っていける
あの世で役に立つ知識はないんです
だから我々はどんな知識人であっても
死後には持っていけません
はい 次のテーマは性格は反乱行動を起こすという
よく学んでも性格が悪ければ知識は役に立たない
知識が役に立ちません
これ こういう例えで考えましょう
とても汚い汚れた器がありまして
ものすごい汚れていて
もう細菌やらもう汚物あると思いましょう
器があるんです こちらすごい豪華なごちそうがあるんです
ごちそうは器に乗らなくちゃあかんでしょ
あの器に乗れる 乗せる
じゃあ食べられる？食べられないでしょ
だから我々はどれほど学者になっても
どれほどの知識人になっても
性格が悪ければ何の役にも立ちません
誰も雇いません 知識を幸福のためではなく
自分も他人も不幸に陥れる目的に使用することもあります
だから性格が悪いんだから
知識人が原子爆弾は作るわ
大量破壊兵器作るわ 化学兵器作るわ
どれこれを悪いことしています
で 小さなスケールでもやっています
お医者さんもいろんなね
もう悪いことやったりもするし
他人に迷惑をかけなくても
自分自身が怒って 怒り
嫉妬 落ち込み 欲 傲慢などの性格にやむはめになったら
自分が不幸に生きる 幸福に生きることもできなくなります
人に迷惑をかけない 特に日本の場合は結構いますね
この 3番目のケースは落ち込んでいるんです
大学は卒業しましたけどね
引きこもっているんです
人間付き合いは下手です
すぐ怒るんです そうすると就職はできない
これでは生きていられないでしょうに
老いた親が食わせてあげることできないでしょうに
それも罪ですよ 大人になった子供を食べ養うならば
これは親が悪行為しているんです
とんでもない親なんです
不親切な 親切な親だったら
まあ大人になった途端追い出さなくちゃあかん
出て行けと これ全部乱れちゃって
道徳はないんだから 親のすねをかじってているんですか？まあいい年なのに
だからその場合も性格は問題ですよ
人間と付き合わないということは性格の問題ですよ
自我がありすぎ お母さんみたいに
ああ 私の子は可愛い可愛いという風にやって欲しがっているんです
誰もそう思いませんよ
社会に入ったら ああ あんたすごい可愛いとかね
磨き上げた性格があった方が良いんですね
ですから 勉強することと同時に
この器になる性格 磨き上げた性格が欠かせないんです
次 知識っていうのは道具です
知識自体自体は人を助けません
ただの道具です 知識で食べられませんでしょ
知識があっても病気治らないでしょ
ただの道具ですよ あれは
自分自身は道具を巧みに使えるプロにならなくてはいけません
道具使ったら役に立つんであって
道具そのものは関係ないんです
だから我々は道具も持つ必要あるし
道具を巧みに使えるプロになる必要もあります
知識技術という道具を巧みに使えるとは
人格的に成長していることです
だから道具使えるということは
人格的に成長しているんだということです
道具だけでは何の役にも立たないのです
また 能力があっても道具がなければ何もできませんね
まあ例えば性格はいいんだけど
知識は全くないんだったらね
またそれもちょっと困りますね
でも性格は良ければなんとかなります
なんとかなります 正しく学ぶとは
人格向上と知識を得るという両方を行うことです
ですから 仏教的には正しく学ぶ
あるいは学ぶとは 人格向上と学問の両方をやらなくちゃあかんですね
これは二輪車であると仏教で語っています
道徳と知識は 昔の車っていうのは二輪車でしたからね
一輪では動きません 牛車とか馬車とかね
2つも必要で 車輪は はい
良い行いをすれば死後幸福というハテナですね
これはよく聞かれる言葉ですからね
このフレーズは常識で一般的
一般仏教徒もよく使います
しかし これだけでは知識はリセットされる
問題はなくなりません
皆様の日本の仏教でも良い行いをすれば
まあ死後幸福だと言いますよ
日本のお寺でも 普通の仏教徒はみんな言ってるし
まあ他の宗教の方々はもしかすると言ってるかもしれません
でも もうそれ行いだけだからね
あ 良いところに生まれたっても
知識は全部リセットされています
釈尊が説かれる学ぶ世界では
性格 人格が死後まで続くことも考えているんです
それでお釈迦様がこれ困ったもんやと
輪廻転生しても衰えないことを学ばなくちゃいけない
これ一番大事な学問で
人格向上 で それを考えているんです
もし磨き上げた性格を過去世から今世にもつなげることができれば
知識を得る作業はいたって簡単なことになります
これを覚えておいてください
この勉強できる人とできない人って 2ついるでしょ
性格のができているならば
例えば過去生で人格向上を頑張って今世で生まれたんです
生まれてもあの勉強はリセットされません
獲得した人格行動向上そのままなんです
その人はいたって簡単に勉強するんです
これはお釈迦様のエピソードではっきりしています
お釈迦様はインドの学問というのはすべて終了するまではだいたい 40年ぐらいかかります
当時ではテキストもないでしょ
全部暗記しなくちゃいけない
膨大な量あります ヴェーダ聖典
印刷していますけどね
相当なもんなんです それでヴェーダ聖典の注釈
ものすごい もう 10倍大きいんです
全部暗記するんです 言語学もやらなくちゃあかん
大変なんです それで王家になってくると
また政治学というものを昔あったんです
法律というものもいろいろあったんです
これ学ぶとね だから昔の人々は何するのか
専門家を雇うんですよ
王様はだらしなくて まあいろいろ専門家
何々大臣 何々大臣で雇って
その連中に頼んで仕事をやってもらうんです
アドバイス受けるんです
だから国はお前いかないんですよ
だってあの連中賄賂取るんだから
お釈迦様が王子の時は全部学んだんです
お釈迦様ちゃんとおっしゃってますよ
先生が喋ろうとしたら
もう私は覚えているんだよと
それだけじゃなくて 注釈まで知ってますよと
どのように解説するべきかってところまで知ってますよと
一発で だから 18 になる前に
学問一切終了しちゃったんです
40 年間の それで 18 で結婚させなくちゃいかんですね
羨ましいですね 昔はもう
で 向こうの王家の人は
あの遊びばっかりしている坊ちゃんには
うちの娘はあげませんと断ったんです
アホやと シッダールタ王子は
なぜかというと 勉強した気配はないんです
先生に怒られたり いろいろでしょ
それから戦争技術を学ぶでしょ
そうすると怪我したり
骨が折ったり 馬から落ちたり
いろいろあるんだからね
何もないんです だから軍人としてもお釈迦様は全部訓練やったんです
そう言われたら お父様がスッドーデの方がね
息子に 「あのね お前のあの娘さんをくれないんだって 」「
そしたらなんで？お前何も学んでないと思ってるんだよ」と
それで 「ああ そうか では発表しましょう」と
言って 両国のみんな集めてもらって
あらゆる技術と学識 全部発表したんです
私はこれもできる これもできる
これもできると 何 10年も訓練しなくちゃいけないことはさっさとやって見せるんです
刀の使い方 弓の使い方
あれやこれや 馬の乗り方とかね
馬に乗って細い板を 細い糸
イタリアはないんです
細い糸を通して弓で撃って見せたんです
それまた馬に乗ってね
で なんでその天才ぶりは
大丈夫です 輪廻転生しながら
菩薩として長い間人格向上してきたんです
それはリセットされないんです
だから全部この世に必要なものはちょろいんです
だって賞味期限があるもんでしょ？それちょろいんです
ちょっと現代的な話にします
学ぶことと脳の変化 認識するたびに
新しい知識や能力を身につけるたびに脳は変化します
何か学んだということは
脳に変化を受けたということです
何か身についた 何かできるようになったということは
脳に新しい配線が現れてできたということなんです
正確にでき上がったプログラムに沿って学ばないと
脳は乱れたり 硬くなったり
柔軟性がなくなったり
伸びることができなくなったりします
長い話は短くしたんです
皆様の脳も毎日変化しているんです
しかし 脳をプログラムを組んで正しく変化することはやってないでしょ
脳の開発プログラムはやってないんです
いろんなことを学ぶと
脳が勝手に変わる 例えば
だらしない 役に立たない
もう悪いことを学ぶと
脳がそのように変わってしまいます
どうでもいいことを学ぶとそうなってしまいます
1 2 3時間パチンコばっかりやっちゃうと
脳がそれに合わせて変わってしまいます
これがとても危険なことなんですよ
ちょっとしたことで脳が変化するんです
だから とっても気をつけて
計画的にプログラムを組んで脳を変化させなくちゃいかんのです
そこで脳があちらこちらに伸びたて
もうなんか雑草みたいな感じで伸びたり伸びなかったり
もういろんなことが起きちゃいますから
なんか手入れしない庭みたいなもんなんですね
脳は 何の役にも立たない
たまに花があるかもしれませんだけど
雑草の方がもっと伸びて高くなっていて美しくはないとかね
それでヘビも入ってきたりとか
だって手入れしてないんだから
だから全く手入れしなかった庭みたいな感じですよ
我々の脳 頭は それでどうなるかというと
混乱するんですね おかしくなるんですよ
その一部ですよ 日本でかいそ様になるのは
脳病気なんです で 脳がいつでも怠けという基本的な感情がありまして
脳がいつでもプログラムを作ってそこでロックしたいんですよ
ロックしてほっとしたいんですね
このロックする必要はあるんだけど
これ逆に危険なんです
あちらこちら脳をロックされ
脳がロックされちゃうと伸びないんです
例えば今更皆様に外国語を学ぼうと思ったら
みんなそんな話 そんな冗談と思ってるでしょ
今更もう遅いと じゃないんです
あれ 脳がロックしてるだけなんです
自分でロックしたんです
人間がいつでも ああ もうこの年だからそんなことはやらなくてもいい
例えば 今からピアノを練習しようかなと思ったら
全然やる気が出てこないでしょ
この年になって でもやろうとすればできますけどね
で ロックするのは至って簡単です
しかし ロック解除する鍵は誰も持ってないんです
ロックしたらしたまんまで
鍵が教えてあげます 集中力
と諦めないことですね
例えば 歳の人がピアノを生まれて初めてやろうとしたら
まあ無理 これはできるわけない
いきなりそんな感じでしょ
でも集中するんです 指 10本動かなくてもいいんです
じゃあ 2本でやりますと
じゃあ次に 3本にします
集中するんです その指に
それから諦めない それでロックが外れるんです
仏教が語る煩悩というのをいう心の汚れは
脳の成長を妨げて硬くしてしまうのです
お釈迦様が 1500ぐらいの煩悩のリストを説かれています
それはまとめて貪瞋痴と 3つにしているんです
これがものすごい敵なんです
これで脳の成長がカチッと止めてロックして硬くするんです
感情に襲われると 人は自分の脳を無意識的にロックするんです
感情っていうのは 怒り
嫉妬 憎しみなどなどですよ
落ち込みとかね そういうものはあんまりも入ってくると
もうまあいいや やめた
諦めたとロック ロック
ロックしていくんです
ロックするのは簡単です
解除は難しいんです ロックされた脳の解除はとても難しいんです
はい えっと 次のセクションに入りますが
楽に学ぶ方法 学ぶことはゲーム感覚でできます
専攻分野を選ぶ まず これから釈尊の教えに沿って説明します
専攻は人格向上を目指すことです
皆様が思っていることじゃないんです
楽に学んでしっかりした人間になりたければ
まず専攻を選んでほしい
専攻は人格向上です これは 2つに分けられます
人格向上は 1 悪い性格
悪感情を制御する 別に難しいことじゃないんですよ
ちっちゃい時からもう悪いことをやめるようにと
難しくないでしょ それは悪いんだからやめなさい
それで終わり いい子はそんなことしませんよとお母さんに教えてあげれば
これは悪い子はするんだよと
そんなのは猿がやるんだよと言えば
子供はしっかり人格向上できますよ
至って簡単です ゲームです 2
善感情を学んで実行する
これ いい子はそんなことやりませんよと
そんなことやるのは猿しかやりませんよとかね
まあ犬だったらそんなことやりますけど
そういう風に言うと 悪いことは子供たちやめます
だって知らないんだからね
子供にとってはなんかお母さんにそう言われるとなんとか楽しいんですね
楽しいんだけど けなされるのが嫌なんですね
それでやめるんですね
次 もうちょっと大きくなってくると
良いことをさせるんですよ
じゃあこういうことをしましょう
こういうことをしましょうとか
じゃあゴミを拾いましょうとかね
公園で遊んだら 全部後片付け
後片付けして帰りましょうよと
そういう風に良いこと
善感情を学んで実行する
善感情と書いた場合は
大人の大人向けに書いたんで
善感情っていうのは 慈しみ
思いやり 優しさなどなどなんです
子供の場合は そこは行動で教えればいいんです
思いやりとかね 行動で教えればいいんです
上級生になると ３悪感情を完全になくすことを目指すんです ４
善を完成することを目指すんです
だから この専攻 専門専攻分野は二つに分けて学ぶんです
まず二つですね それができたら上級生になるんです
上級生の大学院になったような感じで
一日でできることじゃないんで
時間かかります 例えば
悪感情を完全になくすまでは時間かかります
しかし その目的にして頑張るんです
善を完成するまで時間かかります
しかし 頑張ってみるんです
そういうことで 普通の学生と上級生というふうに2つに分けて専攻分野は学ぶんです
次 補助分野も学ぶんです
専攻をサポートする学問のことです
いわゆる皆様の世界では一番大事だと思っていた学問は
私 ブッダの世界ではあれ
補助分野なんです いわゆる補助だけで別になかったんだからといって問題ないんです
数学できなかったんだからで生きていられないということはあり得ませんよ
科学を知らないんだからといって
生きることには何の問題もないんです
だからこれ補助 まあ知った方が知らないよりは便利で
それだけ 新聞を読めた方が読めない方よりは
まあ何かしらいいんです
それだけ 別に読めても読めなくてもどうでもいいんだけどね
そういうわけで思ってください
皆様方はものすごい苦労して
学ぶ学問の世界っていうのは
仏教から見ればただの補助分野なんです
そう思ったら楽でしょ
人は体を維持管理して生きていなくてはならないのです
しかし ただそれだけが人生ではないのです
俗世間にある無数の学問
技術の中から 自分の生計を立てるために
何か簡単なもの 自分にとって完璧にこなせるものを選ぶんです
こんなゲームでやってくださいよ
皆様遅いんですね もう
全部学ぶ必要ないんですよ
何か簡単でできて 完璧にできるもの
一つ選べば 補助分野で
これピアノでもいいし
バイオリンでもいいし
もう車の運転でもいいし
もう何でもいいんです
飛行船操縦士でもよろしい
大学の教授でもよろしいし
服のデザイナーでもよろしいし
漫画家でも何でもいいんですよ
楽な方 しかし しっかりやってほしい
それは だってたった一個だからね
世にあるすべてを学ぶ必要は決してないんです
無駄ですよ だって死んだら終わりですからね
補助分野で成功する秘密
これは皆様の子どもたちに
若者に教えてあげてください
補助分野というのは ある子がまあ歌手になりたいと思う
ある子がもう例えば飛行機の操縦士になりたいと思う
ある若者は医者になりたいと思う
ある人は弁護士になりたい
いろいろあるでしょ たった一個一個
法律は楽ちんで学べる
楽しいと思う人が弁護士になればいいんです
苦労して苦労して 弁護士はかっこいいんだから
何としてでも司法試験を受けますよってのは
あんなのは馬鹿げた話ですよ
難しいんだったらいい加減やめなさいなんですよ
親は医者だから 何としてでも自分も医者にならなくちゃ
でもこれは難しいなとかね
そんな苦労して医者になったっても
人が死ぬだけだからね
やめた方がいいんです
だから 自分にとって気持ちよく
やりたくて楽しい学問を選ぶ
選んでからこれ成功する秘密があるんです
これ皆さん役に立ちますから
ちょっと伸ばして説明します
そこ世間知識も学ぶと難しいんですよ
賞味期限のある学問ですけど
やってみようとしたら難しいこと
すごい難しくなっちゃうんで
覚えられないわ 覚えたって忘れちゃうわ
興味がなくなるわ 競争で負けるわ
能力ある人に追い抜かれるわ
いつまでたってもそなた大勢の一人にしかなれないわね
このような問題は誰にだってあります
うまくいかないね それは自分のために
自我 自我中心に学ぶからです
かっこいいんだからとか
金儲かるんだからとか
認められるんだからと
あまりにも汚いんですよ
心は 自我中心です なんで歌手になりたいのかと
だんだん金が入るんだからと
だったら自業の苦しむ羽目になります
自我中心的に学ぶと 他の仲間が皆ライバルとして
敵として見えてしまうんです
みんな敵の中でいる羽目になるんです
みんな敵 おっかないんでしょ
の心を硬くして 柔軟性を壊す煩悩が溢れ出すんです
それで自我中心的にかっこいいんだからとかね
楽チンして儲かるんだから
これ選んだよとかね と選んじゃうと
みんなライバルになっちゃって
仲間で競争しなくちゃいけないし
そうなってくるといろんなことを起こるでしょ
そうするといろんな怒りがこみ上げてくるわ
落ち込んでいくわ やる気がなくなるわ
怠けが出てくるわ 辞めたくなるわ
えっと やけがさす なんとか言いますね
なんて言いますか やけ
え？やけがさす いろいろ
もう嫌になっちゃって
親もぶん殴りたくなる
別に親は何もやってないんですけど
もう大学でいろんなことがあって
もう親がこんなことやるなと言ったんだからでしょ
この羽目になったのと言って
親ぶん殴ったりもするんですね
そういう風になって どうなるかというと
この悪感情が 煩悩がどんどん出てきて
脳がどんどん硬くなって硬くなっていくんです
脳が低下していくんです
だから成功しないんです
自分は才能がない人間だとそれで勘違いしてしまいます
これは世の中でみんな通過するプログラムです
だからみんな失敗でしょ
結局は正直に言うと まあおだてて言うと
みんな立派な方々ですけど
お世辞を言うと 正直に言えば
大体私は才能がないんだよとね
思っているでしょうね
だからお釈迦様の話 最初から聞けばよかったのに
以下のように学ぶ目的を設定します
この目的設定っていうのは
この なんて言いますか
今本を編集していますけど
そのあれ なんと何の本でしたっけ？忘れちゃった
なんか意欲とかね やる気をね
引き起こす方法なんですけど
その時講演講演本にしますけど
その時私は目的設定が必要だと
目的設定したら 意欲っていうのは自動的に現れるんだと
やる気は そこでここで目的設定するんです
例えば医者になろうと思った
それが目的設定じゃないんで
これはまあどうでもいい
補助分野だからね 弁護士になろうと思った
まあいいんです 補助分野だから
しかし 成功したいでしょ
成功しなかったら意味がないでしょ
医者になろうと思ったのになれなかったら
普通のサラリーマンになって終わっちゃうでしょうね
馬鹿げた話ですよ なると思ったらなりなさい
それ以外選択ないんです
このように目的設定します
これを暗記した方がいいんです
私は他の生命の役に立つ人間になります
見返り ご褒美などを期待せず
社会に貢献します 人の役に立つならば
自分の苦労は喜び 充実感だとします
人の役に立つならば その苦労は私にとって喜びであると
自分の得る知識がどのようにすれば人の役に立つだろうかと常に検討します
あの これでちょこっと蛇足的な説明します
学校でも子供たちに自分で考える能力を与えなくちゃいけないと必死でしょ
だからいろんなくだらないことをやっているんです
子供たちに考える能力を与えるために
あのやり方は仏教から見ればまるっきりダメです
んです はい あんたどう思いますか？あんたどう思いますか？と
くだらんことを思わなくてもいいんだけど
これなんですよ はい あなたはこれはどうすれば役に立つと思う？と聞いて聞かなくちゃいかんです
何か考えてくださいと
で 私も勉強するときは
これをよく大事にしたんですよ
難しい仏教を研究していたんですけども
今の世界でも日本でも
仏教学者は自分の本は誰も読まないと知ってるんです
自分の研究は自分ともう人しか読まないんです
結構給料もらってますけど
私も同じく研究したんですけど
私の知識はかなり大きい
大勢の人々は聞いて役に立ってます
私は学問から離れてすごい長い
離れて学問的研究は一切しない
やめたんです ロックしちゃったんですけど
ロックしてないんだけど
なんかロックしたような感じなんです
やろうとしちゃうと嫌になってくるんです
しかし どんな学者とも対応できます
で 知識は衰えないんですよ
理由は小さい時からもう何か学んだら
これどうすれば役に立つのかと
これどうすれば役に立つのか
その瞬間でちょっと自分なりに検討するんです
あの実行にするかしないかは別な話で
一応この考えはこうすれば役に立つ
ブッダのこの言葉は このように説明するとみんなの役に立つと常に検討してきたんです
以上の目的設定で自我の錯覚が破れます
これでノーノーノーノー
脳がロックできなくなるんです
いくらでも伸びるんです
以上は菩薩の生き方とも言うんです
これ 私はこのお釈迦様がこのもう何何何阿僧祇何とか何とか長い間輪廻転生しながらパーラニターを完成しましたという話があるんですよ
これ 気が遠くなるほど長い時間なんです
4 阿僧祇 なんとか何とか万光年なんですよ
その菩薩になった時 菩薩が何決めたのかという
そこからパクっちゃったんです
だからお釈迦様がもう命をかけて修行したんです
国も戦災産 国を捨てて山に入って修行したんです
体の部品まで布施したんです
お釈迦様がやった修行
菩薩の時 過去世でやった修行っていうのはもう驚きますよ
もう それは一部一部ジャータカ物語に入れてますけど
ジャータカ物語でもそれほど美しく語ってないんです
そこで あの 自分の子供を奴隷として
私はそのエピソードに反対ですけど
ある王子で王様で生まれて
国を離れて出て 森に入って
そこで子供が2人いたんですね
そこであるバラモン人がもう乞食なんですね
奥さんに 奥さんが他の男を作ってるんですね
その男を助けたくて追い出しちゃったんで
私は家の仕事をしたくないんだと
飯かい 持ってこいと 乞食が飯かいはないんだから
だったら あの王様が何でもお布施しますからと言って森に行ったんです
ヒマラヤ山脈に 行ったら菩薩に会って
なんで来たのかというと
実は私の家内はね 飯買い欲しいと言ってるんだから
あなたの子供2人 王子2人なんですよ
飯買いくださいと ったら
菩薩はもう父親だからね
ものすごく悲しくなったみたいです
しかし 私は今世で決めましたから
何かちょうだいと言ったら
必ずそれあげると決めたんだ
これでこの人は私の命と同じ愛着のある子供をちょうだいと言っています
断ると私の決まりは破れますと
ですから 奥さんも連れて行って
奥さんもついて行ったんです
森に で 二人は一応修行しているんです
子供二人は遊んでいるんです
で 奥さんが食べるものを果物探しに森に入っていたんですね
奥先は それであいつはお母さんだから
来る前に子供をあげなくてはいけないと言って
正式的にあげるんです
そこで菩薩の心がものすごく痛くなって
このメス飼いとしてあげているんです
ちっちゃな子供 その苦しみはどうこらえたかというと
これぐらいの苦しみをこらえないと
一切の生命を救うことはできませんよと
だから自分のためじゃないんです
我々に悟り開いて仏教を教えるためなんです
だから この菩薩行から取った項目なんですけど
自我を捨てる 人の役に立つならば
その苦しみは自分が喜びとして受け取る
そういうふうに人格を変えてみると
目的を変えてみると 金儲けるために歌手の練習してないんです
人々の心の悩み 苦しみをなくして勇気を与えたいんだと
元気にしてあげたいんだと
夫婦を仲良くしてあげさせてあげたいんだと
子供がおとなしく勉強する人間にしてあげたいんだと
私の歌声でと思ったら
世界一の歌手になりますよ
誰もそう思ってないでしょ
汚すぎですよ 心は だからこれが仏教でしか学ぶことできない秘密です
お釈迦様も過去生で一切衆生を苦しみから解放しますという目的設定で修行したんです
結果として一切智者になったんです
だから 5 6年で学問 40
年間かかる学問が終わっちゃったんです
どうですかね ブッダの智慧を乗り越えられる生命は存在しません
いまだに ブッダの言葉にケチをつけることは誰にもできません
そこまで智慧完成できたのは
あの目的設定です ですから
誰だって一流になれますよ
私たちも正直に に 真面目に
あの余計な単語を強調したくてつなげたんです
パーリ経典と同じく 正直に
真面目に 真剣に 素直に
本気で菩薩の生きる目的を自分自身の生きる目的として設定して
インチキはダメです 正直に
真面目に 真剣に 素直に
本気で目的設定するんです
設定実行するならば いとも簡単に自分が選んだ分野で一流になれるんです
いとも簡単 ピーナッツ食べるぐらい感じでできます
スリランカでのことわざです
スリランカではキャシュナッツ食べるぐらいと言うんですね
ピーナッツないんです
だから日本で日本風にすれば
あれはピーナッツ食べるぐらいです
というか ポテトチップスでもしてください
どうでもいいんです いとも簡単です
皆様方 もったいないんですよ
勉強に苦労するの もう馬鹿げてるんです
菩薩になってみてください
心を 日本人みたいに観音様を拝んだりとか
あれはもう迷信で何の役にも立ちません
自分が大乗仏教は言ってるだけで
誰も菩薩ぐらやってないんですよ
私は小さいときからもうその生き方を実行してみたんです
小さいときから だからといって別に完璧に生きるわけじゃないよ
アホなことはするわ だらしないこともするわ
喧嘩もするわ いろんなことやってますけど
しかし 自分が生きる目的はこれに
もう菩薩行にしているんです
後で気づいたんです それにこれにこれやってるんだと
一流になれます 一流になりたいと思ったらアウトです
そうするとまた自我が牙を見せますから
一流になりたいならなくとも
どうでも見たら一流になってるんです
世界は一流だと認めますが
自分はただひたむきに人の役に立つことをおかげさまで行っているだけです
ここでやっと日本のおかげさまでという言葉も使えます
自分が貢献しているだけ
それもおかげさまで貢献しているんだと
やってあげているのではないかではないんです
そうしていると みんな一流になるんです
はい これでちょっと皆さん疲れましたから
10分休憩いたします
はい では時間もなくなってますから
次の説明やります はい
次は善行の学び方 今説明したのは補助
善行補助ですからね 善行っていうのは人格向上ね
学び方  これはまあ ずっと私たちやってますから
まあ省略してよろしいと思います
他人の役に立つなどの目的は管轄外ですね
この場合は なんかおかしいね
人格向上する場合は もうこれでもって人の役に立ちますとか
そんな余計なことを思う必要はないんです
人格向上は自分の役に立つ
他人の役に立つ行為です
初めからも役に立ちます
自分のと他人の両方の
だからこちら自力他力はないんです
目的設定はこれです どんな苦労があっても
必ず心を清らかにする
と目的設定する こういう揺らがない気持ちまず作るんです
何があっても心清らかにする
それパーリ語でアディッターナというんですね
アディッターナっていうのは
まあいろいろ日本訳できます
訳してみました 誓願 意欲
決意 悲願 悲壮の願い 決断
そういう何でもいいんです
自分に正直という条件を満たせば
誰でも着々と成長 成功します
それで条件は正直 インチキはできません
これも自分に正直 決断と正直
それで完璧に完成します
この世の中思うほど難しくないんです
仏教の学び方 お釈迦様が誰にも実行できる完全なプログラムを作られたので
私たちは心配する必要はありません
だから 善行は困ったなと
いいえ 困らなくてもちゃんとお釈迦様はプログラムを作ってあります
皆 自我に自我を張って
ブッダの教えを自分の汚れた心を正当化するために変えるから
望む結果が得られないんですよ
お釈迦様は涅槃に入られて
百年二百年たつと みんな偉そうにブッダに教えようとしているんですよ
部派仏教時代 大乗仏教時代
偉そうな偉い 偉いこっちゃですよ
これで結局自分のだらしない性格を正当化したいんですね
それでブッダの教えを改良するんです
だから結果がないんです
道は順番に順序に説かれています
アヌプッビデーサナ アヌプッビパティパダとお釈迦様ははっきりおっしゃっています
それから仏教の場合 スケールが大きい
輪廻を脱出する 輪廻の脱出する
解脱 智慧の完成 性格の完成を目指しているので
仏教学問のスケールは極限に大きい
あの飛行機の操縦士になる程度じゃないんです
極限に大きい 脳みその範囲は超えています
これはウッタリマヌサダンマ アラマリアニャナダッサナという言葉で教えられています
意味は超人法 聖者の知恵
聖者の知見という言葉を使っています
仏教の修行から獲得する人格向上は
今世の一回に限られたものではありません
一旦仏道を始めたら その得たものはここで終わらないんです
死後も 得た資格は残るんです
大学の言葉で言えば 取った単位は持っていけるんです
次の生にも 得た能力は死後も続きます
そこで何か能力身についたら
死後もその能力は続くんです
まあそれだけ じゃあ卒業者って誰ですかと
仏道は終わりの終わりのない作業ではありません
卒業者 合格者 何を学んでも
結局は死後でリセットされます
人格向上は向上はそうではありません
だって単位持ってくるんだからね
しかし 時間がかかると長い間サボると堕落することもあります
これも気をつけなきゃいけない
例えば 2 日間瞑想してみたら
その能力は残るんですけど
それから 4 年間もサボってしまったら
ちょっと 預流舎ソーターパンネになったら絶対落ちることはありません
ですから このくらいにならなくちゃあかんです
これにならなくても もう大体落ちないレベルありますけど
お釈迦様は落ちないとハンコを押さないんですよ
お釈迦様は預流舎になったところで
あなたは絶対落ちませんよと
これからはとハンコを押すんです
お釈迦様のハンコは要りませんだけど
そうやって心がもう開発してしまうんです
衰えないように 阿羅漢になったら合格者で卒業します
それで終了です 皆様知ってるでしょうね
まあ預流果一来果 不還果
阿羅漢果って 4つの段階で合格が決めるんです
学びが終わって無学舎になります
この無学舎というのは仏教用語で学びが終わりました
もうない 学ぶことはパーリ語で成功と言うんです
あ 間違えた これアセコなんです
入れてください アセコ
脳細胞の範囲を超えるんですね
この前もポイント言いました
成長していない心は脳細胞に依存するが
成長すると脳の範囲を超えます
だからそこら辺で脳科学はしっかり
最近の脳科学はしっかり説明しますけどね
今までみんなガチャガチャ言ったことはもう全部やめちゃって
仏教でいうことは全部脳科学者も言ってますね
脳が毎日変化するんだ
いくらでも成長できるんだ
勝手に硬くなったり いろいろ感情で硬くなったりするんだ
強烈に集中すれば脳が開発するんだとかね
今一番最近に脳科学ではちゃんと言ってますから
私も脳科学もにも乗ってみたんです
昔は反対でしたけどもね
昔は有能論かといたんだからね
脳みそ論 今はもう脳と心を別々に単語で科学者は使っているんです
で 仏教の場合はやっぱり修行してみると
やっぱり脳の範囲を超えちゃうんです
心は ヴィパッサナー瞑想でもある程度進んじゃうと
この脳ではもう取り扱いできなくなるんです
それでちゃんとちゃんと心が進んでいくんです
認識次元も超えます 今は我々
目 耳 目 耳 鼻に限ってますからね
それでも超えてしまいます
解脱の智慧は脳を超えています
一切の概念 言葉の範囲を超えています
だから涅槃って何と言ったっても答えられません
もう言葉ないんです 修行する皆
獲得しないか 神通という補助能力を得ることができます
この瞑想実践で神通という補助能力も得られますけど
あまり誰も挑戦しません
であの悟りに解脱に挑戦するんです
宿命智とは 過去のすべての経験をもうクラウドに保存しているようなもので
必要な時 必要なデータにアクセスできます
あの神通の中でお釈迦様はよく使った神通がありまして
宿命地というんですね
いわゆる自分が過去で何やったかと
明確に名前は何でした
何を食べたか どんな性格でしたか
夢は何でしたっけ？全部見事に思い出すことはできます
これは何かわからない
どういう能力かと 今クラウドというものがありますね
パソコンの世界では 私もこのファイルをクラウドに上げたんです
だから どこにいてもこのファイルを呼び寄せるんです
パソコンとインターネットさえあれば
このクラウドはどこにあるかよくわかりませんだけど
一応もうそちらに保存しておいたんです
そのように この神通外から自分の過去生をいつでも取り出せるんです
だからクラウドですから
例えば今私はファイルを持っていないんです
だから楽々にいるんです
お釈迦様もすごい気楽にいるんです
でも説法するときは もう 1億光年の前の出来事を例えに出した方がよろしいと思ったら
さっと取り出して 昔々
私はこういうことをしましたよなんてことなく
それでお釈迦様に他心数もありますね
人の心の状況は読み取れる
で それから人の輪廻転生も言えるんですね
そういう普通の常識でできない人数っていう範囲も
この修行によって得られることはできます
はい これで終了すると思います
後書きで 先入観と洗脳
これ入れるところなかったんですね
講演の中に しかし これ大事なポイントなんです
あの学びが 俗世間的であろうと
仏教的であろうと 先入観とマインドコントロールは問題です
これ かなりハンデになるんですよ
先入観とマインドコントロール
両方とも真理に従ったものであるならば
それほど問題じゃないんです
先入観があるんだけど
例えば仏教の場合は 仏教的には先入観を持っているとあまり問題起きません
例えば 殴っても殴られてはいけません
殴っても殴り返してはいけないとかね
いつでも自由じゃならなくちゃとかね
先入観で持っていたっても問題起きません
が 仏教に限ってないでしょ
先入観は だって仏教徒だったっても
先入観はあんまりかっこよくないんです
しかし 洗脳は決まって危険です
先入観はとんでもない危険なことです
脳の成長できる能力を破壊するんです
私も何人かの洗脳されている人々が私に助けてくれと言われたことがあるんですよ
人の心を改良するのは直するのは
まあまあ坊主だからそれほど難しいことじゃないんですよ
ただ かっこ悪いんだからやってないだけで
本当に困って助けてくれと言ったら助けてあげます
この何人かはもうできなかったんです
洗脳されているんですね
もう壊れてるんです 脳が
復活できない 見解 見 ディッティという仏教用語がありますね
その仏教用語でこの先入観なんですね
ミスるのは 八正道で一番出てくるのは正見でしょ
八正道の反対は邪見なんですね
先入観なんです そこから仏道始まるんです
いわゆるそこからって
先入観からではなくて
先入観を破ることから
宗教は人を洗脳するんです
私は別に特別な恨みないんですよ
宗教の人々と結構仲良くするんです
今度 2 週間スリランカに行って帰りましたけど
空港ではね まあいるわいるわ
みんな頭の上から下まで黒い袋をかぶって
こちらちょこっと薄い何かあって
もういるわいるわ もう金持ちだからね
まあ外国に行ったり来たりするのはその方々多いんですけど
でもスリランカだからね
いや やっぱりそういう方々もちゃんと見ていると挨拶するんですね
礼をするんで 私も礼を返すんですけど
だから別に宗教に何とかっていう感じがないんですけどね
で しかし 学問的に知識的にはもう批判をしたいんですね
宗教は洗脳するんですよ
どんな宗教も 師匠 親などはある程度でマインドコントロールします
皆様も結構マインドコントロールされています
どんな人間も親にマインドコントロールされます
だから 親がしっかりしている人ならば
それは悪い 悪いマインドコントロールにはなりません
で 沙弥出家すると 仏教の場合でも
沙弥ってガキでしょ 遊ぶは悪ガキやるは
もうコントロールできないんですよ
で それで沙弥のテキストという本があります
自分のスリランカで 沙弥の
何て言いますか 法は法じゃないんですね
沙弥のテキストなんですね
これは勉強させるんです
この戒律項目は戒律十なんですけど
沙弥のようになったらそれは五十分に増えるんです
別に項目増えるだけで中身は同じですけどね
項目を変えて変えて同じことを暗記させるんです
分けて分けて それいうと結構洗脳されます
マインドコントロール
マインドコントロールされます
例えば 盗んではいけないとあります
戒律がありますね それで別な項目で
沙弥出家は亡くなって減則
脱走して減則される その項目は自由ですよと
沙弥の資格はなくなる項目と
また同じことを繰り返して暗記させるんです
その時 盗んではならないではなくて
意図的に与えてないものは
糸1本だけでも取ったらお前は終わりやと
だから糸一筋あって あ
これはいいや もらっちゃおうって怖くなるんですよ
沙弥失格になっちゃうんだから
あれは別にいいんですよ
また戒律差し上げれば大丈夫です
それ言ってあげないんです
だってどうせ子供ですから
失敗するのはね 盗ったことはないんですよ
仏教はそういう優しいんですけど
これ見せないんです 見せないでマインドコントロールするんです
それでものはしっかりと戒律を守る
しっかりした人間に成長するんです
そういうことで まあ仏教も悪いことですよ
結局は でも まあ危険にならない範囲で使ってはいるんです
有名なカーラームスって
これは私は講演一つ 二つ
三つぐらいやりました
当時のインド人を悩ませた 10種類の先入観に注意しています
あの聖典にやったからといって信じるなかれよとかね
伝統だからといって信じるなよと
理屈に合うからといって信じるなよと
まあそう言えばそうかもと乗るなよと
そんな話にはと そうかもということでは
やっぱりこの先生は偉いんだと
だから信じます いい加減にしなさいと
先生はいくら有名で偉くたってもね
当てにならないと そういう先入観 10項目をお釈迦様はダメと言って
自由に考察するべきだと
自分で判断しなさいと説かれる経典です
お釈迦様が説法することに決められた時のエピソードでは
皆さまご存知ですね お釈迦様は悟ってからね
説法しないそうと決めたんです
あまりにも内容難しくて
だって脳みそを超えている世界でしょ？どうやって教えるんですかと
それで梵天勧請というものがあって
梵天はこれはダメですよと
社会は破壊しますよと
あんた黙ってたら説法してくださいと
そしたらお釈迦様もね
その慈しみを持って修行したんだから
じゃあまあやろうかなと決めたんですね
やろうかなと決めた時は
決めましたと宣言するんです
宣伝は古いこと パーリ語の下で残っているんです
その 1 行はイエスをたワンとパムンチャントサッダンなんです
この行だけ訳できなくて結構困っているんです
みんな 私は困ってないんです
バカだから で 聞きたい人々はサッダンを話しなさいという訳なんです
サッダンっていうのは信なんですよ
だから信仰を捨てなさいよと
信は捨てなさいよと 信じるなよと
聞きたければって言っちゃうと何かおかしくなっちゃうんです
信じてください これから話します
そうでしょう 常識的な話は
ここでもお釈迦様はやっぱり精密なんですね
これ 信仰 一切の固定概念
先入観を捨てなさいという意味で理解することができます
これから学びますから
これから人格向上しますから
これから心を無限に伸びますから
この邪魔になる先入観を捨てなさいという言葉なんです
はい 今日で学問の基礎
それで終了します ありがとうございます
それでは最後に回向の文を唱え
結束したいと思います
座礁してください 回向の文
仏道僧の三宝に礼拝帰依し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サンビティーヨ ヴィヴァンジャントゥ サンバローグ ヴィナッサトゥ マテーワワッタントラーヨ スキーディーガー
ユッコ バワー バウトゥ サッダマンガラン ラッカントゥ サッダデーヴァタ サッダブッダヌバーヴェーナ サッダダン
マヌバーヴェーナ サッダサンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティ バワントゥ テ アビワダンシリーッサ ニッ
チャン ワッダー パチャヤーナ チャッターロ ダンマ ワッダンティ アユワッノー スカーン バラン
ありがとうございます